deux autres se trouvent sur wikio
d'horreur la légende raconte que seuls
ceux qui mènent être rond seul avec une
juste dans les mains pour voir l'esprit
de l'ensemble n'en avaient pas tomber
d'esprit tout ça on va essayer de
comprendre leur histoire à en vrai on
s'en bat les couilles
on veut juste pas être hanté du cul 23
dans 45 des étudiants entrent dans les
bois il joua week as et joie la vie oui
allez ça c'est une belle intrigue
d'accord donc à des enfants qui sont
portées disparues et tu peux les voir
dans les bois avec une bougie la maison
a brûlé les parents sont morts mais les
corps des enfants n'ont jamais été
trouvées
les gens y viennent ici et ils déposent
d'objets que les enfants sont mis
d'accord dans ce qu'on vient d'entendre
c'est ça voilà il on a laissé un ami
dans la forêt lui ont dit on revient à 6
heures du mat site est encore en vie on
doit survivre la nuit et ses ex à hockey
et on prend des pages
ah ça c'est le butin de monstres ne
pense à rien cours si tu le vois au
dirai comment il s'appelle sackboy de
littlebigplanet sackboy vs nous j'ai cru
voir une sorte de lumière un endroit
regardez là bas c'est des bougies à
tapis sur f pour transférer la light en
fait
ok et du coup je peux prendre cette
bougie à la place assez stressant
d'accord c'est pas les piles quoi c'est
cedac s'élève à 7,1 le temps qu'on parte
on pourra plus la prendre assez
stressant du cul ça mon gars c'est
marrant on fait un truc quoi au coeur
comme ça à kleinfeld dans le coeur c'est
quoi ça on pouvait aller dans ça sert à
rien ça c'est un leurre c'est un [ __ ]
de leur amère on est ok on va nous
montrer par des barbelés parfait oi oi
oi oi
c'est quoi ça
arrête j'ai perdu entre la beauté et la
butte et il va sûrement pas le coup
comme ça comme si j'étais un vulgaire
château où il me faut une bougie là bas
ça brille bougies là bas fait majeur
chic elle est là elle est sûre seul sur
le pou ok on va juste traverser le pont
c'est faux c'est faux on va pas dresser
pour ses proches
c'est marrant ça change un peu des pages
l'a voulu trouver des petites bougies
c'est encore plus stressant je trouve
regardez à elle a plein là on est bien
on a non mais non mais à quel moment on
va pas attendre milan on va prendre
direct cette bougie à l'effet non mais
non j'aurais paniqué [ __ ] je suis
assez bon j'ai allumé allez on va là-bas
on va survivre 7 du mois je vous le dis
nos amis ta gueule âmes ils vont revenir
on pourra leur dire ouais on a vu
l'esprit et austère exceptionnel
vraiment maintenant il nous a suivis
hilarante et ma maison une bougie ta
gueule tu es j'ai des bougies j'ai pas
dit un petit enfant mal éduqués là ok
tout droit tout droit alors attends mon
gars c'était énorme
un optical clermont garde michael bay
dans transformers ohlala écartée elle
allume ça c'est quoi ça c'est la maison
qui a brûlé sa dans laquelle les enfants
sont morts yeux c'est de se mettre là en
fait comme ça tu es un plan d'ensemble
et tu vois là sabri là-bas à regarder
deux endroits tout droit juste pas qui
le petit enfant mal éduqué sur le chemin
touche sa touche pas et touche pas sa
touche bougies ça touche
allez bonne chance résoudre cette énigme
déjà beaucoup trop connu dans le milieu
français excusez moi j'essaie d'être
notre biosphère mais ça marche pas trop
ouais et tout droit moi je suis comme
indiana jones les diamants brio loin
c'est une heure du matin ce donc la
maison a brûlé en 1924 tous les membres
de la famille sont déclarés morts mais
le corps des enfants n'a jamais été
retrouvé les enquêteurs ont interviewé
un résident local et voilà ok j'ai une
heure de là ça recommence là c'est
exactement une chose mais en beaucoup
plus dures genre y va vraiment nous nous
chasser les fesses stay away from her as
à nouveau mousse parfait j'ai envie
d'attendre que la bougie se consume un
peu plus quand même on va se préparer à
partir non
la bouche est la bougie verte vers
bayonne non non j'ai trop attendu
du coup elle est apparue albums seront
utiles je sais quelle bouillie laba par
terre j'ai des allumettes
qu'es-tu affaires petite fille hanter
les fesses tendu c'était tendu bris ok
parfait tout droit il me tend ce jeu les
bougies mon gars ça me tente tellement
fait ouais c'est bien ça sonne à
regarder boom mais tu vois tu connais
tous els matp d'accord alors lu mon gars
et faux en guise et en quoi aller mais
ce qu'il donne indiana jones
ok [ __ ] ils sont tout à l'opposé nous
quoi aulas est hantée quelle idée
d'aller dans cette forêt non non c'est
bon la bougie arrête il ya encore de la
centif footing pile à temps
qu'est ce tu as fait rimerait 5
allumettes on est bien on est bien on
est par contre à sortir d'ici c'est un
endroit fermé stories et des moyens de
bouger
parfait on attends attends mais l'écart
bank run on a juste envie de la qualité
c'est une meuf qui sait cosplay la japan
expo
elle s'est un peu trompé de chemin on
peut le dire tu n'auras pas ma liberté
de trouver des bougies voilà c'est beau
je me fais tp un portail dommage
ok c'est bon aa intéressante des gens
qui vivent là disent qu'ils entendent
j'ai pris quelqu'un de dormir et qui
fait pas mal de bruit donc il suppose
qu'il ya quelque chose qui est vivant et
qui est bien présent dans les bois look
away os il sort d'un arbre moi je fais
noël à 2h du mat dans une forêt hantée
qu'est ce qui se passe japon des cadeaux
aux esprits qui veulent du mal faut
penser à eux on pense pas seul
forcément ils nous veulent du mal après
oui l'homme qui se cache derrière un
arbre j'ai envie de le voir mais pas
trop nous sommes et qui la droiture et
la drogue sur la vache et le bouger elle
se consume beaucoup plus vite mon gars
c'est abusé alors ça c'est la qualité de
l'assiette il n'est pas la même
intention faut pas confondre les petites
bougies artisanales qui fait tout il
pendant plusieurs mois et non
oh oui c'est quoi ça passait lui c'est
lui le mec bizarre qu'il faut jamais
regarder omeyyades merde j'en allumer
une bougie mais j'oublie de la ramasser
je suis une grosse merde alors voilà à
temps elle fait carrément la même taille
c'est que j'avais quoi broyer du
brouillard au ca se déforme home atp en
levant
quoi quoi je calcule d'allumettes direct
à temps seront pas fair play ça est ou
sera bougies quoi c'est comme si on
faisait un épervier qu'elle avait des
rollers non non non
à ma lumière l'a réveillée apparemment
basta réveil difficile et douloureux fdp
webagencies la fin de cette vidéo sur
wii et la difficulté elle fait comme ça
et comme ça vraiment la courbe est pas
normal je passais n'a plus ses cannes et
ce n'est pas m évidemment comme
d'habitude et j'espère aussi que vous
avez passé un super réveillon qui fait
super cool vous avez bien bouffer vous
avez des supers cadeaux que c'est un bon
moment en famille on se retrouvait dans
une prochaine vidéo portez vous bien là
et a très vite que tu puisses